hi I'm Erik Bosse and Halloweens newest
installment will terrify you with
Hollywood's deadliest and mortal killing
machine Jamie Lee Curtis many are
comparing this 2018 Halloween to the
force awakens for the way the two movies
pay homage to the original 70s classics
and for how cool you can look by going
gray
so let us rewatch this movie scene by
scene for all these Easter eggs and
connections that you might have missed
but also for the clever ways this movie
reverses key elements of the original
film to produce a thrilling new chapter
spoiler warning for this movie go watch
Halloween first and then come back here
let's get started this movie opens in
Michael Myers is mental hospital with an
interesting close-up of a clock notice
how the heads of the clock point to
10:00 and 3:00 though the framing
suggests that there could be a 30 or a
31 numbers that definitely would not be
on the face of a clock I know but I
think the filmmakers included this
detail as a nod to the movies title 10
31 Halloween true crime podcasters Aaron
Corey and Dana Haines meet with Michael
psychiatrist dr. Sartain and their chat
references dr. Loomis the psychiatrist
from the original films played by Donald
Pleasence later in this movie Laurie
Strode actually says to Sartain you're
the new Loomis now during the scene
there's also a very subtle close-up of
Sartain spin which we later find out
contains a concealed blade now it's hard
to tell but it looked like it had the
shape of a curved human spine attached
to the back of a skull piece perhaps a
reference to a psychiatrist interest in
the anatomy of the spinal cord and the
brain but it just goes to show that
Sartain has been using this secret blade
for a while now and has probably been
waiting for his chance to help Michael
Myers escape these podcasters triggering
Michael with his old mask reminding him
of his mortal enemy Laurie Strode
might be the first step of that master
plan by certeyn Michael Myers in this
movie is played by two actors James Jude
Courtney and they also brought back the
original Michael actor Nick Castle to
play him for a few key moments and from
here we jump into the opening credits
which is a direct parallel to the
original film's opening credits the
director of this movie David Gordon
Green working with his eastbound and
down / Vice Principals team of Danny
McBride and Jeff Bradley worked closely
with the original director John
Carpenter to recapture the classic
aesthetic Carpenter actually covered his
iconic score for the movie composing a
slightly updated version with
son Cody and with the composer Daniel
Davies and you can hear this new music
here and see how the titles have the
same orange typeface as before as well
as of course the image of the jacket
lantern however this jacket lantern now
begins molded and decayed with green
reversing the shot to show it gradually
reforming this reflects Michael Myers
his resurrection his reawakening but
also the way this whole movie reverses
the roles of Michael Myers and Lori
Aaron describes his concept in the next
scene as the podcasters make the way to
the fortified home of Laurie Strode
Jamie Lee Curtis he theorizes that one
monster may have created another and
we'll see how this movie has reversed
Laurie's role from scream Queen damsel
in distress to a deadly predator
stalking its prey just like Michael
Myers is this movie is set exactly 40
years after the original story and we
see a Laureus spent these past four
decades recovering from her trauma by
taking paranoid precautions gradually
preparing to trap and kill Michael Myers
and yet this version of the character is
definitely inspired by the
deconstruction of that final girl trope
that we saw in the Terminator and aliens
series characters like Sarah Connor and
Ripley definitely took over their
sequels as over-prepared badasses that
no one really took seriously until the
end when they were proven right and you
could argue that some other Halloween
movies may have already attempted this
transition into heroism with Laurie
Strode but I would say none of them have
been quite as effective as this latest
chapter and next we meet Laurie's
estranged family her daughter Karen
played by Judy Greer and Karen's husband
Jay played by toby huss and their
daughter Alison played by Andy matichek
we first see Karen and J setting mouse
traps now this is actually an
interesting setup for the film's final
sequence the booby-trapped home that
Laurie raised Karen in is essentially a
mousetrap for Michael Myers and notice
how when one of these mouse traps
prematurely Springs on Jay that could be
foreshadowing his inability to survive
and its kind of battle Allison's
boyfriend it's named Cameron Alam and
Jay mentions growing up with Cameron's
father Lani Alam now this is a reference
to the original Halloween Lani was one
of those kids and Haddonfield who
bullies Tommy Doyle in the first movie
next Alison and their friends Vicki and
Dave walked through the neighborhoods of
Haddonfield discussing their Halloween
plans and yeah this is another tonal
parallel to the original witch carpenter
used similar voyeuristic camera movement
to follow Laurie and her friends on
their way to school throughout these
same streets these kids reference those
specific events bringing up the theory
Michael Myers was Lori's brother Alison
dismisses that as a rumor that some
people made up to make themselves feel
better this is all a meta reference to
the twist of Halloween 2 in which
Michael and Lori were revealed as
siblings at struggle that's Michael
Myers sister but this movie erases the
events of everything after the first
film replacing the whole timeline as one
direct sequel and Danny McBride
confirmed that Michael and Laurie are no
longer related analysis high school the
original Halloween parallels continue si
sits in the same exact desk of her
classroom as her grandmother dead back
left corner tuning out as her teacher
lectures on the same subject fate and
the first movie the teacher cites the
philosopher Samuels who doesn't exist by
the way and Laurie answers a question
saying that Samuels considers fate a
natural secular element of her lives
like earth water and fire but in this
movie the teacher updates a lecture
talking about Frankel's interpretation
saying that Frankel said fate took a
different course now it sounds like
she's referring to the philosopher
Victor Frankel he's a philosopher and
Holocaust survivor who wrote in his book
man's search for meaning that fates are
under our own control that we can decide
whether we are worthy of our sufferings
and he could see how that concept
applies to Laurie's arc in this movie
the fact that this moment is updating
the fate lecture reflects the deeper
theme of the story that Laurie isn't
locked into a fate outside of her
control anymore that she can actually
control her own destiny and give her
past suffering meaning and by the way
the voice of the teacher here might
sound familiar it's actually a cameo by
actor PJ Souls who played Laurie's
friend Linda in the original movie and
of course this shot of Alison looking
out the window and realizes the one
who's watching her it's another example
of the reversal of roles idea that I
brought up before and the original movie
Laurie looked out the window to see
Michael staring back at her but here
Alison sees her grandmother Laurie
Laurie is essentially replaced Michael
as the hunter of this movie she must
become that which is feared to defeat
what makes her fearful moving on there's
a quick scene of Laurie watching Michael
as his bus transfers mental patients to
the new facility and she's drinking
shots in her truck and she screams
there's actually a theory that Laurie
could have rammed this bus off the road
intentionally causing Michael's escape
in order to lure him in and finally kill
him there's a rumor that this could have
been in an earlier version of the movie
that's explaining some of her lines
throughout the film and why we never
really see footage of the accident
so but just to be clear this final cut
that we saw included more than enough
clues that Sartain was definitely
responsible afterward Laurie joins the
family dinner at the restaurant and if
you listen closely to Laurie's mumbling
she refers to Michael as the shape this
is a nod to the original film which
listed Nick Castle only as the shape in
the credits it's a term that was
otherwise never spoken out loud in the
movie next there's this hunter and his
son and their truck on the road and one
of the best Easter Egg the movie comes
up here the radio is playing a song
called close to me this song was
actually improvised by Jamie Lee Curtis
and John Carpenter for the original film
they were on a very very small budget
and couldn't afford the rights to a real
song so carpenter had Curtis sing and
Hum this fake country song to herself
and the imagery here once again borrows
from the original film escaped mental
patients dressed in white appearing
suddenly in the headlights and Michael
Myers popping up in the backseat of the
car strangling the victim in the
driver's seat as deputy Hawkins gets on
the case we return to another familiar
location the Haddonfield cemetery Loomis
visited the same grave of Michael's
sister Judith Myers and now the
gravestone that Michael stole has been
returned to its rightful place Michael
catches up to the podcasters at the gas
station killing them both now there have
been past scenes at gas stations and
rest stops throughout the Halloween
series and Halloween for in h2o the guys
after 11 movies some locations are just
gonna be reused without having to be a
direct reference to it though I do think
the closeup of Dana's feet going limp as
Michael chokes her to death could be a
reference to the same shot of how Bob
died in the first movie and when Michael
finally reunites with his mask you can
hear the sound of his breathing original
actor Nick Castle actually recorded this
audio since it's so distinctive to the
characters presence when Hawkins and the
sheriff examine the crime scene and
opened up Michaels file they refer to
the crimes as the baby-sitter murders
now the baby suit of ours is actually
John Carpenter's original title for the
film Halloween and this brings us to
Michael's arrival and Haddonfield on
Halloween night first he runs into a kid
with a cowboy hat in a boom box that's
actually a nod to a kid that we saw in
Halloween - and this is immediately
followed by another Halloween -
reference with Michael killing a woman
in curlers and a pink bathrobe and
stealing her kitchen knife he did the
same exact thing to mrs. Elrod in
Halloween - meanwhile notice some of the
nearby trick-or-treaters were wearing
which skull and jack-o'-lantern masks
this is a nod to Halloween 3
season two the which probably the most
divisive movie of the series it features
a novelty company putting deadly
computer chips in which skull and
jack-o'-lantern masks that could be
triggered by TV jingles yeah went to
some weird places
meanwhile Allison friends Vicki is
babysitting the most hilarious kid in
the world Julian amusing this house to
hook up with her boyfriend Dave this
whole sequence is pretty much a
restatement of Linda and Bob from the
first film Michael kills Dave and pretty
much the same way that he killed Bob he
stabs him to a wall and he poses Vicki
similarly with a jack-o'-lantern beside
her body but here he poses her by
putting a ghost sheet over her exactly
like the one that he wore in the first
movie and he'll also see how there's a
ton of shots of the laundry hanging up
dry outside which the director included
to evoke the famous Michael jump scare
in the laundry line in the original
Hawkins and Laurie arrived on the scene
and Laurie scares a bunch of kids you'll
notice that one of those kids wears a
silver shamrock costume that's a nod to
the costume that Michael wore as a kid
on the night of his first kill Michael
gets away and Laurie and her family and
the cops they start saying they all
regroup except for Alison so Laurie
leaves a voicemail and Alice's phone
barking at her do as I say
apparently Laurie says do as I say a few
times throughout the Halloween series
she says them to the two kids in the
first movie and she says do as I say to
her son and his girlfriend in h2o but
again 11 movies only so many word
combinations Michael then stalks Alison
and that loser who tried to be a rebound
killed Oscar and then freaked out Alison
the notice these shots of Alison wailing
in the street she pounds on stranger's
doors desperately this all reminds me of
that bystander effect moment of the
first movie remember when Laurie was
begging a neighbor to help to no avail
Alison's a bit luckier but only for a
moment cuz she had sup in the hands of
Sartain who killed Hawkins with this
super penknife and it's our teen reveals
that he was the reason the bus crashed
and Michael was able to escape he wants
to see Michael out in the wild and
reunite him with Laurie because they
defined each other and he wants to see
true evil in action
yeah it doesn't totally make sense but
anyway they all end up back at Laurie's
house where Michael kills Sartain and
the two cops or a guardian ed turns
their heads into flesh o lanterns and he
kills J and we finally arrived at the
showdown so Laurie's house is full of
interesting set details first little
detail she kept her Sun Hat remember
that was the one that hung on her wall
and her bedroom in the first movie but
also you can see this dollhouse this is
the one that Karen played with as a girl
and it's an exact replica of the Myers
house the house where he killed his
sister Judith in 1963 so Lori keeps this
in her home as a way to carry the weight
Michael since her leaving his able to
survive is kind of her unfinished
business as Lori sweets to the house
looking for Michael who camera lingers
on closets shuttered doors once again
we're seeing the role reversal back in a
Doyle house Laurie hid from Michael in a
closet just like this but now she is the
hunter searching for the parade Michael
tries to turn the tables on Laurie
upstairs filling the room with her
target mannequins and trying to scare
her with Jays body which lops out just
like Bob and Nancy's corpses did in the
first movie but if you look closely
Laurie has designed this room to have
almost the exact same layout with the
closet and the French doors that open
out to a balcony as the room back in the
Doyle house she has been reliving that
moment over and over in her mind for 40
years now she's kind of JLo and nothing
Michael Myers
she's luring him directly into her
mousetrap where she'll have the upper
hand and it all comes full circle when
Michael launches her over the balcony he
looks down to see her motionless body on
the ground but when he looks back she's
gone this is a great call back she's
pulling the same move that he pulled on
Loomis back in the first movie this all
leads to three generations of the strode
women trapping Michael in the basement
and torching the house Darrin actually
pretends to panic in order to lure
Michael down there she knows it's the
perfect bait for him and then she fires
a rifle if you look closely could see
its marked with KS for Karen strode
suggesting that she actually grew up
with her mother's firearm training so
killing Michael Myers by burning him
alive is kind of a play from the finale
of Halloween
- when Loomis kills him the same way but
that movie shows us Michael's burning
body whereas this movie explicitly does
not in fact if you listen closely to the
end credits you can hear Michael Myers
still breathing through his mask the
producers of this movie always intended
to shoot two of these new Halloween
movies back to back but they wanted to
wait to see how well the first one did
before they committed to a second but
now this movie was a big hit I think
it's safe to assume that Michael Myers
will return but I will say it's pretty
insane how hard it is to kill this dude
like even if you are evil incarnate you
don't just take a gunshot to the face
and sit back up
I would love to explore this mystery
more in-depth in a separate video so let
me know if you want to see it and for a
deeper explanation of Halloween's ending
and how this final sneak
might actually have all been
orchestrated by Laurie from the
beginning go watch my other video gonna
do a lot of interesting questions there
but my question right now for you guys
is what do you think is more important
to Laurie protecting her family from
Michael Myers out of maternal instinct
or just killing him to satisfy her own
selfish vengeful desires I want to hear
your thoughts on this so comment down
below and follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a loss for a bunch of
interesting projects that I'm working on
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
deep dives into everything movies and TV
horror films like Halloween but also
Game of Thrones stranger things Marvel
Star Wars really anything you care about
that I don't entirely hate which is
everything I am not capable of hate
Lumis looked into my eyes and saw your
love run all you want hello Paul Rudd
you aged so well how do you look so
young four decades of decades